the uk government has been accused of
not doing enough with a new report by
the national audit office criticizing
its response to the pandemic
this pandemic has exposed the
vulnerability to whole system
emergencies although the government had
plans for an influenza pandemic it did
not have detailed plans for many
non-health consequences and some health
consequences of a pandemic like covert
19. there was limited oversight and
assurance of plans in place and many
pre-pandemic plans were not adequate
it was my grandfather who died on
christmas eve he um
[Music]
went in for a routine
water infection absolutely nothing wrong
with him
caught covered and died as a lot of
people did in this country so the fact
that my grandfather in rural west
england was taken out by a virus that
started in china because our government
still allowed people to fly in from
business flights from wuhan in february
last year
um it's pretty shocking uh matt hancock
giving away 600 000 units of ppe to
china as a gift in february
doesn't really help so our nurses had to
improvise with bin bags
um yeah this there's numerous stories of
uh our health services being let down by
the likes of mr hancock and uh boris
johnson the very fact they didn't close
the borders um goes to show that they
didn't understand the stress this would
have on our nhs along with the mental
health of our nurses and doctors who
have been absolute heroes this entire
time
well the report also claims too that
despite warnings about potential
shortcomings ahead of the outbreak the
government failed to act and suggested
that officials were actually too wrapped
up in preparations for brexit however
downing street has defended its response
saying that the pandemic was
unprecedented
we have always said there are lessons to
be learned from the pandemic and have
committed to a full public inquiry in
spring
we prepare for a range of scenarios and
while there were extensive arrangements
in place this is an unprecedented
pandemic that has challenged health
systems around the world
well ellis tustin again does say though
that the unprecedented nature of the
pandemic can't be used as an excuse
tons of things are unprecedented
walking into the road is unprecedented
you never know what's going to happen
when you walk into the street
but we
walk into the street with the knowledge
that we have to look left and right
these people didn't we don't need
character kind of based buffoonery in
charge we need a meritocracy and we need
the scientists we need people to
actually understand what they're talking
about
this whole
process has been done by people that
don't understand science don't take it
seriously it took them 56 days to
introduce masks countries like korea and
china have been using mass for years but
for some reason in britain we just
didn't get the memo our government was
fought of money first they thought well
you know we can either
keep our borders open which would
potentially
you know
kill a large uh population of the
british people but the economy would
potentially survive longer or we can
close it the economy will take a hit
what they've done is they tried to do
option a it didn't work we've lost loads
of people and the economy has took an
absolute slap
you